look at what is drawn on the whiteboard
it's a flat surface a plane basically
extends indefinitely in all directions
this surface extends indefinitely
throughout it will be a plane this is
just a part of a plane a flat screen
television a tablet or a mobile phone
are all examples of portions or parts of
a plane this football on the other hand
is not a plane surface but the important
question is how do we name a plane the
first thing we should know that a plane
has infinite points on its surface say
these three points are a B and C this
plane can be called ABC but there is a
catch the three points we used to name
the plane should not form a straight
line if we have a point D on the plane
such that a B and D form a straight line
then this plane cannot be called a B D
can it be called a DC of course yes it
can be called a DC as a D and C do not
form a straight line it can also be
named using single letters if we write
an M here this can also be called plane
M
you